welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with an
incredible discovery on display just
yesterday at a museum in Canada an
exhibit featuring the largest t-rex ever
found was open to the public and that's
not the creatures only distinction Jamie
yuccas has the story
Scotty roamed the earth some 67 million
years ago this massive Beast of the
Mesozoic era was discovered here in the
Frenchman River Valley in Canada at that
time it was a floodplain with lush
vegetation it's just huge Wes Long
helped reconstruct Scottie
after spending a decade digging the
towering t-rex out of hard sandstone
you'd be zipping away with your air
hammer and all of a sudden a piece of
rock would fly off and there's like a
beautiful tooth there the thigh bone of
Scottie is here Tim Tech Eric was there
too he showed us some of Scotty's actual
bones and the t-rex Discovery Center and
you can still see the serrations on the
side of the tooth you can put your
finger down there and this is so sharp
mm-hmm I feel like if I hit it hard
I could almost cut myself there there
are fossils of animals that if you touch
it the wrong way you will bleed so this
is just one back bone yeah can I hold it
you can there's a weight to it there is
definitely weight to it scientists found
they had about 65% of the skeleton
intact including the skull the lower jaw
vertebrae from the neck back and tail
and parts of the hips leg and shoulder
Scottie lived a hard-knock life
Scott Persons is the paleontologist who
led the study of this remarkable find
he says the bones reveal much about
Scotty's life it's got evidence of a
broken jaw of an impacted tooth it's got
a section of its tail where the
vertebrae seem to have been compressed
possibly from the bite of another
taranis or
Hollywood has long had a fascination
with the king of the carnivores at 42
feet long this Tyrannosaurus Rex was the
size of a city bus weighed nearly 20,000
pounds and lived for 30 years the
largest and oldest t-rex ever to be
found dinosaurs are nature they're the
animal kingdom on the grandest scale
Scottie is making its public debut and
when you have the biggest baddest
dinosaur on the planet it's likely Dino
mania will not be far behind for CBS
this morning Saturday Jamie yuccas
Regina Canada 42 feet that's crazy
yeah impressive and now they're just
little lizards they're kind of big I saw
an iguana that's a little that's a
little